je pense que les taxis c'est un exemple
passionnant parce que saab à un peu en
brèche le discours sur la mondialisation
aussi sur le fait qu'il y ait une
augmentation généralisée des niveaux de
vie le textile aujourd'hui c'est une
industrie aussi polluante c'est parce
que les niveaux de production soit
absolument colossaux donc charles adrien
l'a dit donc c'est à peu près 40 de
vêtements par habitant an dans le monde
sait à peu près 100 milliards de
vêtements produits chaque année et
pourquoi autant pourquoi autant parce
que on exploite les gens pour les payer
deux mois fait hausser la délocalisation
a permis aussi de réduire les coûts de
main d'oeuvre ce qui permet en retour
d'augmenter la production et les
salaires dans le secteur textile baisse
en fait depuis des années dans le haut
niveau mondial parce qu'il ya une course
au dumping pour aller jusqu'en ethiopie
maintenant même le bangladesh ça leur
suffit plus mais c'est aussi grâce à
d'énergie pas cher au charbon c'est à
dire que vous parlez du nucléaire vous
parlez des sources d'énergie il ya des
pays qui aujourd'hui voilà fonctionne
avec les énergies les moins chers
possibles c'est comme ça qu'on pollue et
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'égalité sur
secteur d'ici pas le monde entier ne
profite pas de l'industrie textile c'est
vraiment une production pour les pays
très riche qui exploitent jusqu'à
l'esclavagisme quand on parle des
ouigours et d'autres populations les
gens donc on peut pas d'avoir un
discours aussi général donc il ya
vraiment une question de nous ce qu'on
demande c'est pas réduire le niveau de
vie de tout le monde voilà par le
plaisir de rationaliser les agents pour
la morale pour une espèce de moura qui
tomberait du ciel dont la question c'est
qu'on demande avant tout un encadrement
des pratiques les plus extrêmes des
excès les plus graves des
multinationales et une meilleure équité
est en fait une meilleure équité aussi
entre les entre les pays
à
[Musique]